in comes Panera centers it's tipped away
laier gets it back to Jacob trouba here's
Miller up ahead panan fires across he
was looking for laier shot by trouba
save off the right shoulder of McKenzie
Blackwood leap for duclair he breaks in he
scores that's what he does Anthony duclair
with great great speed this time he was
hanging and he got the pass out and scores
on the Breakaway they've scored the first
goal of the game this was after a save and
then just a long pass as duclair got behind
everybody that's a beautiful move he's always
had offensive ability and Kyle Burrows looked
up before he got to the puck saw duclair
down on the other end of the ice and gave
him a perfect pass lead for hurdle over comes
gusterson rers starting to change unit CH in
front big chance and grin with stop oh a huge
play by Jimmy VC back pass out Fox to Zan Jad
back to Fox looks that's off the skate of
hurle jaad to panan paner moving shooting
his right Timmy panan it's a power play
goal Blackwood had no chance didn't see
it all the traffic in front prer the main
stay gets right in front of Blackwood he's
looking he's looking he's still looking for the
puck when it goes off the post and in what a
shot Blackwood has no idea that the puck has
passed him bino with a block he leads all
forwards to the NHL and block shots Pito spent
the most of the last two seasons with San Jose
they score Ryan Carpenter it went off the glove
of Jonathan Quick he got a piece but not enough
and the sharks have the lead for the second time
moved up to third line Center and Rangers had it
and can't clear it coie lost it and eventually
the shot just off the glove over the over the
pad so the Rangers had had a chance to clear two
of their players gson and coie and I think David
Quinn did a good job coaching him up and his H
to come PA r scor on the rebound it's our T paner
again his 12th most point game of the season
T Panera get it Thro Che behind the net he'll
try and stuff it in right there good save by
Blackwood but no one picked up Panera who was
all alone in front he had three players around him
here's the move there a beautiful first save but
Blackwood had no chance and Snider back forth
McDonald on him 325 to go first period tied
two two rder moves in bed the head by brinsky
and fr score oh what a setup prider to Saban
Jed a thing of beauty reachers lead 3 to2 poor
coverage in front of the San Jose net there it
is again the pass from crrider as Advantage
ad blackwood's big but he wasn't big enough
there easy and good row with Miller and Schneider
for the Rangers here's McDonald again gets it back
and shoots save no it went by quick it got through
him and the Sharks score on the power play on the
big shot by McDonald the game is tied 33 and
then the this last shot I don't I'm not sure
that they even saw it looked like it went off the
post and then maybe off quick and in here comes a
shot again from McDonald duclair was there a
short time ago Alexi laier against McKenzie
Blackwood on the penalty shot L forier and stopped
by Blackwood tender you'll see him fake the fake
the backand there and then back to the forand
Blackwood did a nice job staying with him wow
he wouldn't go for that that move right there
nice save out in front stopped by quick Miller to
trouba bino nice pass to
The Net score will Cy with a
beauty Rangers lead 4 to three it starts with
Miller holds on to it off the glass to trouba
trouba looks up throws it into the air so that
Bonino can knock it down and then the streaking
will kie and St takes the pass and the quick
wrist shot beautiful little pass kie doesn't
have to slow down at the Blue Line and that
beautiful wrist shot gives the Rangers the
lead down the boards behind the net Benning
Benning bumped on the play by panan up the
boards duclair has it little pass to zedin
Knocked Away by Miller picked up running
deep back here to brinsky save rebound
score timing panan give him the hats
it's a hatrick for our K panarin line to
keep the Play Alive you'll see him right
there reaches now he keeps it alive he'll
get one shot Blackwood has trouble with
it and eventually paner puts it in and he
moved it up to L prier thr check tied up H
fell down Rangers able to keep it in paner pass
through to Miller Miller with room shoots he's
Stills DeAndre Miller adding offense to
his outstanding D and the rers lead 6 to
three that Panera made then he made another
one on the other side before ending up with
the puck stealing it and getting it to Miller
for the goal but not more than a couple in the
offensive zone in this period Fox with the
keep in Zab banad has it try to get it to
krider Anthony duclair scored the first goal of
the game that's redirected same in on the rebound
zerin young Fabian zerland breaks the ranger
streak of three goals the long cross eyes pass
is defended and then here comes duclair
with his speed Zin with the rebound able
to move it up to thas hurle taken away by laier
hurle takes it back moves in on on Miller Waits
finds the trailer down the middle Addison
they score a redirection in front by barov
he just came back from injury and look out
it's 6 to5 well adderson I believe came off
the bench he got the pass you won't see him
yet hurdle will stop up and find him he waits
he waits and there's adderson comes to the
middle and again a wide open player in the
side of the net so the first one was a rebound
this one was a redirection no chance on either
of those two goals grin comes in does he get a
shot off yes but he missed wide and this one is
over what a wild back and forth
game and the Rangers win it 6 to5